el parís son real man cada vez más cerca
de su sueño imposible convertirse en
campeona de europa este martes dio un
paso muy importante en esa dirección a
clasificarse por primera vez en su
historia a la final de la liga de
campeones- lo hizo al vencer tres goles
por cero a los alemanes de lifesynch un
partido que comenzó digamos parejo pero
con el primer gol que llegó a los 13
minutos gracias a marquinhos los
parisinos se llenaron de confianza para
hacerse con la posesión de la pelota en
el minuto 42 llegó el segundo tanto
gracias a di maria y pues esta posesión
de la pelota y dominio ya se confirmó en
el segundo tiempo a pesar de los cambios
que hizo giuliana girls man el director
técnico de los alemanes que quiso poner
un equipo un poco más ofensivo
parís hallaría su victoria con un tercer
tanto gracias a un cabezazo de juan
bernat en el minuto 55 hay que decir que
la figura de este partido es ángel
dimaría 2 pase gol autora de la segundo
tanto y pues esta victoria que han
celebrado los parisinos aquí presentes
en a lisboa en la capital
portugal ellos claramente no pueden
entrar a los estadios porque por ahora
ustedes saben por razones del cob y de
los partidos se juegan es sin público
pero lo festejaron viéndolo aquí en
varios bares y restaurantes de la
capital ahora ellos y su club esperan
saber cuál será su contrincante en la
final de este domingo que se disputará
en el estadio da luz aquí también a una
lisboa será al término del partido que
se disputa este miércoles entre el
olympique lyon y el bayern munich